[Musik]
hey meine lieben heute gibt es
eigentlich glaube ein zum trend
notierendes rezept wie du bist doch gar
nichts zu sagen okay das war nämlich das
zurück also heute gibt es ein rezept
sind brownies mit weißer schokolade aber
jetzt nicht wie ihr denkt dass man das
im teig verarbeitet und dann backt wir
drücken weiße weiße schokoladenstückchen
in den heißen brei nach dem backen und
ich freue mich riesig darauf ist gleich
zu machen aber habe ich das wort
probiert worbis gesehen das war in
istanbul urlaub ich sag mal ja immer
gerne genau im gleichen laden wohl auch
sebastian chips gegessen haben und ich
sammle er im urlaub immer gerne
inspiration und versuchen immer rezepte
zusammenzustellen und deswegen zeige ich
euch jetzt hier erstmal den brownie teig
wir fangen so direkt an gar nicht
drumherum quatschen ich habe jetzt hier
meinen topf auf dem herd ihr könnt doch
über dem wasserbad machen wenn ihr euch
unsicher seid weil das ganze muss jetzt
langsam erhitzt und geschmolzen werden
ich habe hier butter und zucker
schokolade und die gebe ich hätte meinen
top und die in die ganz genaue
mengenangaben stehen hier unten in der
video beschreibung
[Musik]
anschließend mit einmal umfüllen und 15
minuten abkühlen lassen das machen wir
deshalb weil jetzt die eier dazu kommen
und dafür muss die masse ein bisschen
abgekühlt sein damit ihr kein rührei
erhaltet gebe ich jetzt mit dazu nach
der kriegszeit anschließend auch zucker
und rohrzucker ich hab jetzt in zucker
aufgeteilt wird die 50 müsst ihr nicht
machen ich mag diesen einzigen geschmack
wenn ihr keine rohrzucker habt einen
braunen zucker wenn ihr den ich da habt
einfach haushaltszucker verwenden so ich
höre das jetzt ein mit dem schneebesen
wir brauchen auch keine maschine heute
dann geht es weiter mit den trockenen
zutaten
[Musik]
dazu kommt noch eine prise salz die hebt
den süßen geschmack und anschließend
mail und bacau hin zu 7 und 1 drin ganz
wichtig den bug und nicht den trinkt
cacau
so und jetzt ist der teig auch schon
fertig offen ist vor gehalt das ist auch
ganz wichtig und jetzt bereite ich hier
mein main back rahmen vor ich habe jetzt
hier mein backblech das ist aus eigener
herstellung das ist ebenmäßig ihr kennt
immer das problem mit den start
abbrechen die haben eine wölbung und so
könnte garantieren dass er gleichmäßig
durch backt und ihr könnt es verstellen
das heißt für nahezu jeden backofen
geeignet verlege ich euch auf jeden fall
eine infobox
da wird jetzt ein backpapier um und
jetzt komm ich meine buck kam zum
einsatz den habe ich jetzt auf die
kleinste einstellung dessen 17 x 25 cm
einmal drauflegen und jetzt den teig
einfüllen das riecht schon so
schokoladig kommt schon richtig lust
drauf
[Musik]
selbst noch schön glatt verstreichen und
jetzt wird der brauch die gebacken bei
160 grad ober und unterhitze wie gesagt
ganz wichtig vorheizen für ca 32 minuten
und dann nicht komplett ausgelassen weil
dann geht's weiter mit der weißen
schokolade und habe damit und hamza com
wir haben unseren kaffee vergessen
ich hab den schon vorbereitet so viel
lieber soll der brauneck dürfte jetzt
mit 32 minuten lang backen und wenn ihr
die stäbchen probe macht dann bleibt auf
jeden fall noch was hängen das muss auch
so sein weil der soll er richtig facci
seine cent brownie so und jetzt habe ich
den ungefähr acht minuten lang stehen
lassen darf nicht komplett auskühlen
weil jetzt kommt die weiße schokolade
zum einsatz und so habe ich mich einfach
tafeln genommen und so ein bisschen den
vielen kästchen eingeteilt und jetzt
drücken wir die weiße schokolade einfach
regelmäßig in den braunen nicht ganz bis
zum boden aber so bis zur hälfte
ungefähr
[Musik]
und das ist dass leute ein wahr
gewordener traum ich mein gott wir
beenden was die umsätze die
hauptgesellschafterin also sie also
essen verbindet einfach wissen gerade so
hin und weg also gerade arbeite kann man
nicht lief wir haben einfach so gefühlt
gedacht gehen ja einfach genial und
sowieso also wer ist sowieso
ihr müsst nicht alles auf einmal essen
aber doch aber ich rate euch das ganze
langsam zu essen also es direkt ein
stück zu lange so nicht abrufen
diesmal kommen wir jetzt schon essen wir
müssen nicht warten dass es abkühlt und
ok ok und noch mal ein kurzer tipp wenn
ihr das im nächsten tag ist jürg wachsen
dieses lachen gegeben und wenn ihr das
am nächsten tag verspeist
am nächsten tag ganz einfach in die
mikrowelle stecken für ein paar sekunden
genial einfach nur genial ja also euch
jetzt ganz viel freude beim nachbacken
bitte bitte probiert es unbedingt aus
und schreibt mir die kommentare wie ihr
das von it und ansonsten abonniert gerne
meinen kanal komplett kostenlos wenn das
noch nicht getan hat spätestens jetzt
allerhöchste eisenbahn und dann sehen
wir uns auch noch im nächsten rezept
video wieder
[Musik]